let's appreciate the brilliance michael
holly of our boy but i know how much he
has shooting he's not in your backyard
mookie betts i know
look i was so
mike
you talk about him being in the backyard
he was so
fun to watch here
uh and and not just because of all the
things that he can do on the field now
let me just point out everything the
mookie best can do because he has no
weaknesses in baseball i know mike
trout's the best player in baseball but
mookie bets is my number two uh doesn't
strike out a lot hits for power can hit
for average for those who still like
average because some some saber
matricians aren't in the average anymore
you know average doesn't matter it's on
base percentage but he'll give you that
too good on base percentage good ops
he's a gold club
outfielder
okay and he's a great face right he's a
platinum glove outfielder at this point
he plays the game and if you see this
like what he does what he did last night
this is how he plays there's like a
spirit of joy uh in mookie bets and
there's a
there's a comfortable in his own skin
kind of vibe to him you never see him
whether it's in baseball or in
interviews you never see him trying to
do too much and never try to see him
kind of go out
of of of that comfort zone of like who
he is he's just very okay very content
yeah with being mookie vets and that
team
i'm telling you like this this will go
down i know it's just one game i'm not
going to overreact to it they are one
zip in this series and you know how i
feel personally about the tampa bay rays
what i want to happen
uh i want them to be bloody what do you
think what do you think about payroll
just where do you stand on the payroll
disparity between these two teams
they're just curious did you drink last
night
what happened last night did you
did you get drunk what do you come down
i did not i just wonder when you come
down on this this storyline just just
curious yeah
okay yeah you see you're a troll i got
it um
but this is what you this is what
happens when you pay for talent look at
all the talent they have on that team
your starting pitcher last night clayton
kershaw
a well-paid guy and a really talented
guy so happy and i know so happy to see
him do his thing in the world series
because i've always i know we all got to
show
postseason narrative really glad to see
him do this thing last night go ahead
sorry you know i'm just going to say you
know we all got to the point where we
thought he would never
do well in the postseason again he
didn't have to face the cardinals the
cardinals really wore him out uh over
the years and the braves they got him in
the nlcs
but clayton kershaw versus the raise
it's a great matchup for him and watch
out if they wanted to they don't have to
when it comes to the sweep when they try
to close out game four
because that's what it's gonna be if
they wanted to bring them back for game
four they could
they only threw 77 pitches last night it
could have gone more
but i don't want to talk about that's
what i want to talk about mike this yeah
i didn't i didn't come to you for your
baseball analysis i need what's what's
the tell me what the emotional part of
this is for you here's the emotional
part
this is why mookie bets
is so good for baseball because when you
watch this game when you watch this game
if you're if you don't if you're not a
dodgers fan if you're not a raise fan
okay but everybody else if you watch the
game think about the enjoyment think
about how much fun it was to watch him
just disrupt that fifth inning and just
to be all over the place and this is
what this is one of the problems with
baseball i know a lot of people talk
about african-american participation in
baseball and that's an issue too that's
an issue all right
they don't market their players very
well for whatever reason yeah
but beyond that
even beyond that
it got to the point and i'm not
anti-analytics mike
but it got to the point where the sport
became so rooted in analytics
that they forgot
some of the joyful and impactful parts
of the game analytics
will tell you that stolen bases don't
matter
the stolen basis it's not worth the risk
that that you know analytics is more
station the station so that's why right
you know billy beans teams
which have never been here by the way in
the world series but that's why billy
beans teams
are stationary station
yeah in a run and you think about those
old oakland a's teams
with ricky henderson you think about
kansas city with uh willie wilson you
think about the car it's the it's the
biggest
teams it's the baseball we grew up on
it's the baseball we grew up on like
like the idea of baseball being boring
is not the game we were raised on it's
not the game we felt absolutely plenty
of action in baseball no it is not just
how he plays
it's his overall personality look i
didn't cover him the way you did in
boston but fortunately you know recently
uh since he got traded to the dodgers i
have gotten a chance not just to get to
know him but some of his inner circle as
well
classy
doesn't do it justice
uh just the type of guy
that doesn't take himself too seriously
doesn't uh you know view himself as
above anyone even though look he should
already be a face of baseball hopefully
baseball
sees this as an opportunity to to seize
upon
who he is and what he's about and his
two-way street though what an incredible
barely it is an awesome street two-way
street well in all fairness i want him
to see it too i think he that's what i'm
getting to i think he does i think he
does understand especially in this
moment in this zeitgeist if you will i
think he does understand that if
baseball
if he's going to be an ambassador to get
to the for the game
both broadly and specifically within the
black community that he does have to
step up his game and i can tell you
firsthand that he has taken steps toward
stepping into that position because you
talked about mike trout one of the
things about mike trout
is he's more interested in studying the
weather than giving people all access
into his process and i'm not knocking
him that's just not how he's wired he's
not wired to beat his face of baseball
mookie has been to this point more of a
reluctant face but i think he's pushing
himself and or being pushed into being
more of a face of baseball and and
putting it on a t for the sport to say
listen here's your guy
but back to how we got here though
and a lot of people in within the
dodgers will tell you that they got here
because day one even though he's not an
order person
oriented per
he definitely like laid down hey this is
what we have to do guys this is what i
expected myself this is what we need to
expect of one another to take this to
the next level and even though he's new
this team goes as he goes and if they're
gonna break through finally it's going
to be because of his leadership his
quiet leadership his subtle leadership
but his his story and his work ethic are
just incredible if you don't know about
it go look it up
but all right mike remind me michael
but just i need you to remind me of
something
how do you get arrogant what you're
gonna do
no no i'm not even trying to troll you
i'm just starting i'm trying to figure
out like it's not like he was a prospect
that had promise
he had one of the greatest seasons in
the history of sport of the sport in
2018. the red sox knew what they had
it's not like they're they're not the
rays right i just honestly i'm not even
this is not rhetorical this is i'm not
no husband it's so funny educate me so
funny
trading him
to the doctor like why didn't they sign
him for crying out loud listen mike
what's so funny what's so beautiful
about this moment this moment right here
before you said that i promise you i was
about to say mike i got a comment you
were going
okay i got a confession because you
might be wondering and you say to me
sometimes amen what's up with like
why you keep going in on a raise like
this why keep going on a raise and so
part of it is
that whole their their financial
restraint their fiscal responsibility
and i think it's fiscal recklessness
because their payroll is a joke and when
they don't win this world series they're
gonna need they're gonna find out they
need players like justin turner and
mookie betts and bellinger and anne and
clayton kershaw for that matter their
pitching staff is pretty good but they
need more help
to really be at a championship level but
the reason i'm so bitter about it
lately it's because mookie betts
was traded to the dodgers
in the name of that tampa nonsense and
who traded him to the dodgers you know
who the general manager of the red sox
is now they have a new general manager i
lose track i lose track
his name is heim bloom
uh-huh he came from tampa
oh he came from tampa
so so what they're doing
in boston boston what they're doing is
bringing in a tampa model i'm gonna
pair their payroll down to a responsible
manageable level
build through the system
you know be one of those teams pull
things and yeah y'all out there thinking
that there was a chance he would come
back
y'all got a hard time i'm saying y'all
just because you represent i tell you
who likes it y'all hearts was so broken
when he signed an extension
you know who likes it though baseball
media eats it up baseball media like
those teams like they love tampa
oh that's a team oh look what they do
it's all it's all cerebral
so i would say if um if the rays win i'd
say the press box will be happy and the
board room will be i think so
if the doctors win the rest of us gonna
be happy because it's just yeah i think
i i i definitely think i think
that's what the sport is supposed to be